so now we'll take a look and see if our
changes got propagated to the api's
explorer you may find that you need to
refresh the api's explorer to get the
latest changes so you drill down through
the conference API and again with a safe
profile look at the safe profile and
here you'll see now here you'll see now
that we have the request body properties
showing up or the request property
fields showing up if you're clicking it
and this is really cool you'll see the
add a property menu you go ahead and
click back bring the menu up and it'll
show you the properties that you're
allowed to add so we're going to add a
display name let's say we'll set it to
lauren and now we're going to go ahead
and add another property we'll add a
t-shirt size set that to M for medium
and we execute it and you see the
request that got sent the display name
was Lauren t-shirt size M we also see
the response which is the profile that
got created the display name is lauren
t-shirt size is M so these are the same
fields that are defined in the profile
form class which is the input parameter
to the save profile method so hopefully
you've learned how you can restrict the
input to the API by passing the argument
in the API function now it's your turn
to update the save profile function in
conference API to take the profile form
paramah as an input argument you'll be
implementing the code marked with to do
one look for the one the method has a
couple different places where you'll
need to be adding code but this time
you're just doing the places mark to do
one go ahead and add the profile form
argument to the save profile method in
the conference API class and go ahead
and do the other sections marked to do
one to get the arguments out of the
profile form argument that gets passed
in when you've made your changes run
your app on localhost and visit it in
the api's explorer and then go ahead and
explore see what happens when you
execute the save conference function try
executing it with and without providing
the display name and the t-shirt size
parameters when you've tested it out on
localhost and it's working like you
think it should go ahead and deploy your
app to appspot then when you're ready
you can enter your app ID here and press
a bit so you dasa d can test your code